all right
a high-speed chase back-to-back
officer-involved shootings and multiple
crashes are all caught on video when a
California man allegedly steals a city
vehicle and leads officers on an
hours-long Pursuit ending in a SWAT
situation
the incident happened on August 9th in
Northern Los Angeles at about 5 30 that
evening multiple emergency calls came in
for reports of a hit and run
oh yeah hi so I just was involved in a
hit and run crash it's um I think I got
the correct uh plates but it was um
atic
everyone's fine I parked on the side I
moved the car was able to still move to
the side so it's all good I'm not um
is there any city property above any
street signs like
[Music]
no but the car that hit me was from the
water and power so maybe callers
reported the vehicle involved was a
Department of Water and Power or DWP SUV
the car that hit you works with a DWP
truck
yeah okay how were you were you how
could you tell did it have like a city
emblem or what how did you know it was a
City truck
it had water and power it had a
California exempt place I also have the
plate number but it just said Water and
Power on the side okay and so they
didn't stop
no they didn't stop it to the left
another caller reported the vehicle may
be stolen given that the man driving the
SUV was shirtless LA City 9-1-1 operator
hi uh good evening I am calling to
report um there was a gentleman a white
gentleman driving a fire department uh
car vehicle it was it was good I know
the DWP and he just took the red light I
don't know if it was stolen because the
guy was shirtless and he like went in
the middle of traffic and he was heading
north down San Fernando Road
you saw this at Hampton down the road
and what Cross Street yeah
yes
Paxton
[Music]
and uh what time does this happen
just right now okay what color it was a
pickup truck or what kind of dwc car it
was a one it was a white DWP is that a
pickup truck or what kind of car was it
a third caller reported the driver was
acting erratic and maybe intoxicated
hi um they just crashed a guy with the
water and power truck crashed into my
mother-in-law's house and he hit my
mother-in-law my boyfriend
does anybody need an ambulance
yeah well I don't think they need an
ambulance
okay so a DWP truck hit your house and
hit your mother
yes he was a guy with tattoos and I
guess he was drunk or something is he
still there
no he left
and the truck said ladwp on it
yes officials eventually determined the
vehicle was stolen the suspect behind
the wheel was identified as 28 year old
Manuel Ramirez LAPD officers essentially
caught up with Ramirez who was stopped
in immediate when they attempted to pull
him over he drove off running through
both a stop sign and red light
okay no just go
this one
good okay
[Music]
pull over
all right he's going proceed bro yeah
yeah
[Music]
video shows Ramirez drive on the wrong
side of the road as officers follow
closely behind
Yuba
approaching San Fernando
Five freeway
eventually officials follow Ramirez onto
the freeway for what they called a
lengthy Pursuit on the freeway
minutes later officers follow the stolen
vehicle off the freeway
[Music]
I have a vehicle
for money turn around
After exiting the freeway Ramirez drove
the SUV into a business parking lot that
didn't have a way out video shows him
ran through a closed gate before turning
around and driving back the way he came
but Ramirez doesn't stop and crashes
into multiple LAPD squad cars as he
attempts to get away
these same moments are captured on
multiple officers body camera video and
dash camera recordings all from slightly
different angles
next right follow it up
I have a beautiful
photo you turn around
turn around
hey
follow it up
I have a vehicle
yeah
I'm all right I'm all right
I have the Beautiful
morning
after all this Ramirez's vehicle steers
over a nearby Hill crashing into another
van video shows officers rushed toward
this new scene
[Applause]
First Responders call to Ramirez telling
him to get out of the vehicle that is
now temporarily disabled
we have one person getting commands on
this side
one person give me commands
we don't want to hurt him we just want
to get up
okay that's close enough we just hit we
got enough time we got enough time
grab some less lethal just grab some
less lethal do you have any there taser
but suddenly the SUV begins to work
again and Ramirez drives it towards
officers that's when they open fire
twice
right here stop stop
[Applause]
civilian to get out
hey put some spike strips right here
these same moments are caught on
multiple recordings showing back to back
officer-involved shootings all from
different angles yeah
[Music]
reverse thing
has been changing of the vehicle reverse
thing
Ramirez crashes into multiple squad cars
as he makes a break for it after that
multiple First Responders chase him down
when Ramirez's vehicle finally comes to
a stop a SWAT team arrives to the scene
one shooter one lesson
officials then work to bring Ramirez
medical assistants as he's taken into
custody
we need to get him on the ground
Ramirez was taken to the hospital and
treated for a fractured leg and gunshot
wounds he's since been released and now
faces eight charges of assault with a
deadly weapon on a police officer the
officer involves shootings in this case
are still under investigation reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie